today we're going to talk about the 23
different signs that your body is
deficient in vital nutrients now the
problem with me teaching you this is
you're going to pretty much evaluate
everyone you know so you're going to
have to withhold that temptation because
people will be offended if you start
explaining why they have these little
white specks on their nails or why they
might have erectile dysfunction all
right now let me first just tell you the
three reasons why
uh people are deficient okay number one
uh their guts um are damaged so they
can't absorb nutrition so that's called
male absorption it's a digestive barrier
now it could also be that you're missing
a gallbladder or you're lacking bile and
you can't pull in the fat soluble
vitamins vitamin a
d e and vitamin k
or it could be you're not eating enough
of the right foods or the foods that
you're eating are not nutrient dense
which is a big problem
because the soils unfortunately are
really really poor quality so if you're
growing food on
soil that's not soil but it's actually
dirt
you might get a really nice looking
tomato but it's going to be tasteless
why because the flavor chemicals are
tied in with the nutrient density so we
get these beautiful looking like
vegetables
that
tastes like nothing
and then you're going to be craving
doritos and wanting other spices to try
to flavor them up when in fact they
should normally come there with
nutrition so unfortunately the farmers
sell these products based on weight
and volume not nutrient dense type foods
and then the third way that you become
deficient is consuming refined foods and
sugars that deplete you and rob you of
nutrition so let's just go through the
list number one
white spot on your nail what does that
mean that is a zinc deficiency but it's
not really a zinc deficiency it is
consuming too much sugar that robs you
of zinc so if you look at your nail and
you see this little white speck about
halfway down the nail you know about
three months ago
you had a lot of sugar or refined
carbohydrate like let's say you had this
huge birthday party and you ate the
whole cake
and that depleted zinc from your body
creating that little white speck so you
have two options you can stop eating
sugar or you can take some zinc all
right number two oily skin this is
usually a problem with the oil glands of
your body is called sebaceous glands
that make something called sebum which
is a type of oil and that usually occurs
when you have an imbalance with
androgens you're producing too many
androgens which is the male hormone and
so one really key nutrient to regulate
androgens
is zinc okay so oily skin can be greatly
improved if you start taking trace
minerals specifically zinc now if you're
female and you have too many androgens
you may have something called polycystic
ovarian syndrome
and in that case
that's coming from too much insulin
because the carbs are too high and of
course the combination of that sugar
depleting zinc as well as lacking zinc
and having an uncontrolled androgen
situation so with oily skin you just
need to take some zinc and you need to
make sure that your sugar is not very
high so as you can see zinc is involved
with
quite a few things all right number
three cracking on the corners of your
mouth right here or cracked back of your
heels okay
so that is a vitamin b2 deficiency it
could also be a vitamin b3 deficiency
but it definitely involves the b
vitamins so the b vitamins are very very
important in preventing
like these small fissures okay on your
skin and so if you have enough b2 or b3
you won't get them
now you see a lot of people in the
winter that get these fissures in their
skin
and that normally comes because they
don't have enough vitamin d because
they're not in the sun and vitamin d
feeds the microbes
and your microbes make the b vitamins so
that is a connection between crack heals
cracked corners of your mouth which i
used to have as a kid
and it could be very easily handled by
taking vitamin d
or vitamin b2 in the form of nutritional
yeast all right next one is flaking skin
a lot of times you'll see that around
the nose or even the forehead where the
skin is kind of like a scaling flakiness
that is a deficiency of omega-3 fatty
acids and that occurs because you're
consuming too much omega-6 fatty acids
and so the essential fatty acids that
our body needs because the body doesn't
make it is both omega-3 and omega-6 so
if your ratios are off because you're
doing too much six in nf3
that's what happens with the skin
it becomes dry flaky white little flakes
usually around the nose or the forehead
so you need to do two things you need to
start cutting down the omega-6 fatty
acids that means reduce the amount of
nuts or peanut butter or chicken
or
fried foods
or going out to restaurants or fast food
all are very high in omega-6 like corn
oil soy oil cotton seed oil and you need
to eat more fish sardines and cod liver
oil in fact cod liver oil would be the
quickest thing to
handle this flaking skin all right
number five yellow eyes that is a
jaundice situation it's a liver problem
it could be a gallbladder problem where
the where the byproducts of your red
blood cells are backing up
through the system through the liver and
into the blood and the byproduct of
these red blood cells have a yellow
color okay
and so if your skin or your whites of
your eyes are yellow that is definitely
a backup of the liver and the
gallbladder and that is usually a
deficiency of bile salts okay so bile
salts bile salts allow the flow
of
stuff through the liver and through the
bile ducts
and if you don't have enough bile this
thickened cholesterol sludge tends to
back up
and you develop these white eyes so a
simple remedy would be to take some
purified bile salts to open up this kind
of clogged drain plug to allow the body
to eliminate the byproduct of red blood
cells
all right number six chronic cough if
someone has a chronic cough
they usually have a calcium deficiency
so a little calcium especially at night
works like magic for these chronic
coughs calcium both improves the immune
system but it also relaxes the throat
and the larynx just like you might want
to take for cramping in your calves so
basically it helps something called
laryngeal spasm or this tightness in the
structures of your throat okay so you
might want to try that the type of
calcium i would recommend is calcium
lactate okay not calcium carbonate and
you don't need much maybe 200 milligrams
before you go to bed all right number
seven
bleeding gums or redden swollen
gums okay in your mouth that is a
classic vitamin c deficiency another
term would be subclinical vitamin c or a
very mild version of scurvy okay now in
the vitamin c complex we have different
parts and one part is vitamin p
which is the bioflavonoids and they
don't call it vitamin p anymore they
that was an older term but that p stood
for permeability and
or vascular permeability so in other
words
the blood that goes through the
capillaries
leaks okay and if it leaks you get all
sorts of issues and one being bleeding
gums and you can also get nosebleeds as
well but bleeding gums or red and gums
is classic vitamin c deficiency so you
need to consume
more leafy greens as well as avoid sugar
because the chemistry of sugar is almost
identical to vitamin c and if the body
has sugar any vitamin c that you're
getting from foods or a supplement will
not go in the body will always take up
glucose or sugar before vitamin c
okay
number seven number eight night vision
issues so let's say you can't see in the
dark or you're driving when it's raining
and you're just having a hard time you
know seeing clear that is a classic
vitamin a deficiency or night blindness
now are people usually deficient in
vitamin a well around the world they are
so there's a lot of people that have a
vitamin a deficiency simply because
they're eating a lot of
cereals and refined grains and they may
even be eating plant sources of vitamin
a
but those are precursors like
beta-carotene for example they call it
vitamin a but it's not the active form
of vitamin a called retinol retinol
usually comes from animal products like
dairy or butter
or
fish fatty fish
definitely cod liver oil
and
animal liver like beef liver for example
has a lot of vitamin a and so if you're
trying to get your vitamin a from plants
it's going to be very hard for you to
convert that into the active form of
vitamin a which is retinol but a really
good source of retinol would be egg
yolks okay so if you want to have enough
retinol just eat some egg yolks and you
will definitely get enough and then
you'll start seeing better the other
thing to look at with vitamin a is your
ability to absorb it because maybe
you don't have enough bile or maybe your
gallbladder is removed or you have some
liver issue because it's like fatty for
example then you can't absorb
vitamin a because vitamin a is a fat
soluble vitamin it could be one cause
all right next one is chapped lips
the cause of chapped lips is the same
cause as cracking in the corners of the
mouth or on the heels it's a vitamin
b2 deficiency
and so what would create a b2 deficiency
it's either you're consuming too many
refined grains that are depleting b2
because naturally
the b vitamins especially b2 are
normally in grains but basically when
you refine them they get lost so one
really good thing would be to stop
eating grains
any grains and the second thing you want
to do is start taking nutritional yeast
with nutritional yeast i would always
get it unfortified you'll get a complete
spectrum of the b vitamins and you'll
notice your skin
much much better i mean if you take a
look at some of the b vitamin
deficiencies like real severe
deficiencies you get conditions like
pellegra and with pellegra you have
devastating effects
on your skin because b vitamins are not
just about giving you energy they're
about helping you form uh normal tissue
so it's not too roughened or cracked
it's nice and soft a lot of times people
will start using chapstick or certain
type of lotions or oils on their lips
but what they find is that
maybe an hour later it's right back if
not worse to being chapped because
sometimes they put other ingredients
into these products like they might put
alcohol or mineral oil which pulls out a
lot of the key nutrients or fats that
you need to keep your skin
the right texture all right next one is
the pitting edema on the top of your
foot or your ankles
this is a deficiency of potassium okay
when you don't have enough potassium
or the ratios of potassium versus sodium
like sodium is way too high and
potassium is way too low and by the way
refined sugar causes you to retain
sodium and deplete potassium that's why
diabetics a lot many times
have so much sugar in their blood that
they get a lot of swelling especially in
the ankles and the feet and if you push
your finger into
the foot or the ankle it leaves a dent
okay now believe it or not when i had
blood sugar issues a long ago in my
mid-30s i used to have pitting edema and
i didn't even know what it was i would
press into my ankle i'm like what is
that dent that was a severe potassium
deficiency so you want to start eating
foods high in potassium okay and that
would be any of the leafy greens but you
need volumes you need large salads
things like that that will give you
enough potassium
versus consuming more salt okay salt's
okay as long as you have enough
potassium or you might want to get a
quality electrolyte with a lot of
potassium but that will push fluid out
of the ankles very very quickly now next
one is craving ice okay
if you're craving ice
chances are you're deficient in iron
okay you see this with kids sometimes
you see this with females who are going
through their menstruation where they're
losing blood and iron and they're
becoming anemic they start eating more
ice they're trying to get iron but
unfortunately ice doesn't give you iron
so you end up still deficient the best
sources of the iron that you need is red
meat you can get it from liver you can
get it from eggs and for some reason if
you can't eat any of those products you
can also get them in a supplement but
not an iron supplement i would recommend
a supplement that is either a grass-fed
liver extract or
believe it or not there are spleen
extract products that are loaded with
iron okay so that's one way to get it
all right next one is angina that's
chest pain
so that is
where the heart is cramping
and
your heart is having an attack
and usually it's referred down the left
arm
that is a classic vitamin e deficiency
there's two things you need to know
about vitamin e what creates a
deficiency usually is refined
grains okay as in the breads the pasta
the cereal the crackers the biscuits
when you consume those products that
normally have a good amount of vitamin e
in it but when they add chlorine to
bleach it they oxidize it and they kill
all the vitamin e when they when it sits
on the shelf all that vitamin e is lost
and then when you consume those products
it creates a vitamin e deficiency the
most important tissue for vitamin e
is the inside of your arteries and if
you don't have enough vitamin e you get
a lot of
rusting and oxidation
and you start getting
clots the formation of calcium and all
sorts of things that come in there so
vitamin e is very very important and so
the best way to prevent vitamin e
deficiency is to stop doing the refined
grains and if you want a very good
vitamin e i would get the type that's a
tocotrinol
not a tocopherol the tocotrienols work
about 50 times stronger than the
tocopherols
and so
it really is great for angina type chest
pain all right number 13 leg or calf
cramps that is a magnesium deficiency
okay where do you get magnesium well
it's at the heart of chlorophyll where
do you get chlorophyll
from green
plants okay so again we're coming back
to that salad where you get good amount
of magnesium there's also potassium in
there chlorophyll other things but when
you get light cramps chances are you're
probably missing magnesium you need more
and they usually go away there's other
deficiencies that might lead to cramps
like potassium even sodium
vitamin b1 and i've done videos on that
but the most common one is the magnesium
deficiency all right number 14
irritability excessive thinking feeling
nervous tension
even grouchy or angry
is a b1 deficiency if you take a little
nutritional yeast
if you're irritable boy it just chills
you out you'll feel really calm
you'll be nice to be around people will
like you a lot better also before you go
to bed if you have excessive thinking
just take some nutritional yeast before
you go to bed and that you can get it in
tablets as well i'll put a link down
below for more information but you talk
about turning off that excessive mind
thinking solving all the problems of the
world which prevents you from sleep it's
really nice to be able to go to bed and
not have to solve a million problems so
you can drift off and sleep all right
15. asthma
asthma is a situation where you have
inflammation in the lungs
and this
can be greatly improved with vitamin d
so if you're deficient in vitamin d
which most asthmatics are boy that can
just reduce inflammation and help you
breathe this is why during the summer
months when kids that have asthma
they're outside they're exposed to the
sun their symptoms go away there's a
very very important video on a breathing
method that can help asthma i'll put
that down below if you haven't seen it
but there's a really important way of
breathing to pull someone out of an
asthmatic attack you know within minutes
so you can check that out 16 loss of the
outer eyebrows okay
this is usually a thyroid problem
or an iodine deficiency situation where
they're not able to make the thyroid
hormones because when you get to like t4
t3 you're really looking at the number
of iodine molecules in that thyroid
hormone t4 is an inactive thyroid
hormone t3 is the active form because
the body strips off an iodine molecule
so if you don't have enough of either t4
t3 then you could potentially lose the
outer eyebrows as one of the symptoms so
if you don't have eyebrows or you don't
have the outside just take some iodine
in the form of seek help that's one of
the best sources
tightness in the right trap area right
through here okay all the way through
here if you have tightness right there
suspect gallbladder and suspect a lack
of bile salts if you don't have the bile
salts things get all kind of stuck
underneath the right rib cage there's a
little nerve called the phrenic nerve
that goes right up to the right side
and so if you take purified bile salts
that thins the bile allows the drainage
okay and all of a sudden your right trap
feels loose and it feels better okay i
have additional information on that i
will share that in the description but
tightness in the right trap
9 out of 10 times it's totally
gallbladder related because you don't
have enough bile and it's getting all
stuck and jammed up it's backing up into
the system showing up in your right trap
18. nightmares one of the best ways to
get rid of a nightmare is to take b1
nutritional yeast there's this little
thing in the brain called the amygdala
which regulates the emotion of fear okay
so it's involved in this fear response
and so of course nightmares involve
fear and its function is very very
similar to
what the adrenals are all about which is
like a stress gland but it's mainly
involving that emotion of fear and
there's receptors for thyamine and if
you take more b1 thymine uh boy does
that just chill a person out and they
feel better and they don't have
nightmares anymore so
if your kids have nightmares give them a
little nutritional yeast but the real
question is why are they deficient
because they're consuming refined
carbohydrates in the form of
all the refined grains the breads the
pasta the cereal the crackers those
things as well as sugar so you need to
handle that as well
19. craving for salty chips at night
if your body is deficient in sodium okay
you're going to crave salt
but
if you're exercising a lot and sweating
the need for sodium goes up and so one
of the symptoms or signs of a salt
deficiency or a sodium deficiency is
craving for salt okay so if you're
craving for salt at night in the form of
chips
the next day i would start to increase
the amount of
sea salt and not sodium chloride in your
diet okay
so start beefing that up putting on your
food maybe even putting some in some
water and drinking that where you get to
the point at night you no longer crave
salty chips okay then we know you have
enough
and so for years
i had this false idea that salt was bad
and i rarely consumed salt so i always
ate foods
lacking salt lacking fat
of course at night i was downing all
these chips and salty popcorn and salty
doritos but during the day i was pretty
much salt free so i had no concept of
nutrition or this whole idea that salt
was not bad if it was in the form of sea
salt and if i had enough potassium okay
i didn't know that at the time but if
you're craving salty chips at night
you need to
balance out your electrolytes by adding
more sea salt and make sure you have
enough potassium as well but you will
find those cravings will go away all
right number 20 stiff low back
or low back pain
is usually a vitamin d deficiency
especially if it's in the winter and all
you need to do is take some good amount
of vitamin d or you can even make your
own vitamin d i'll put that link down
below if you haven't seen my recent
video but vitamin d is one of the best
things to get rid of inflammation
fast anywhere in the body especially in
the lower back i would recommend taking
at least 10 000
international units per day
and it might be beneficial to take it
right before bed or at a meal because if
you take it right before bed it actually
enhances your sleep and if you take it
with meals it's better absorbed and the
type of vitamin d i recommend is my own
brand and of course i'm not biased
but i am sarcastic but in my vitamin d i
have i put the k2 in there i put the mct
oil so that way you don't have to take
extra oil everything gets absorbed
nicely all right the next one is 21
you're craving dirt okay now
normally most people don't crave dirt
but sometimes kids crave dirt okay or
even
women that are menstruating
losing blood anemic are craving dirt
what they're trying to get
is iron even if you're animals like even
your dog crave starts eating dirt
they need iron okay and the best source
of iron is red meat it gives you the the
best form of iron that's bio-available
versus consuming spinach things like
that so if you have anemia or you need
iron
red meat would be the best thing to take
or
some liver with onions of course all
right number 22 erectile dysfunction
that's low testosterone that is a
deficiency of zinc zinc is one of the
best things to increase testosterone and
handle this
symptom and lastly 23 depression if
someone's depressed
they're usually vitamin d deficient
vitamin d
greatly boosts
serotonin which is a neurotransmitter
and so it's like a natural form of
prozac without the side effects so if
you're depressed or know someone that's
depressed boy just give them a little
vitamin d and just see how fast their
mood elevates another thing to try as a
side note is to start to do more fasting
that really elevates the mood as well
now if you haven't seen my video
on how to figure out liver problems by
looking at someone's foot
check that out i put it right here
you